my name is Muhammad Allah says some
economics professor the School of
Business at the American University in
Cairo regarding the question of how can
we accelerate growth in the Middle East
and our world I think actually I have a
fundamental disagreement with the
premise of the question growth has been
happening in the Arab world the Arab
world has been over the past 10 to 20
years growing over the past 10 years
probably growing more than the world
average take a country like Egypt has
been growing at a very very reasonable
6.7% I think the problem has been how
can we make the growth more inclusive
how can we make the growth actually not
only help the rich wealthy well and
well-connected of the elite rather how
can we make the growth really reach out
to the disenfranchised enfranchise how
can it reach to the - to women - they
use to the poor to the chanty towns and
what have you and when it comes to that
question I think going forward we really
have to to put an emphasis on an
inclusive process whereby women should
become part of the of the of the fabric
of the governance fabric both on the
private and public sector where the
youth are are sought out in their
capacity as decision-makers and not only
as junior analysts on both on all
attributes one way of doing that for the
youth is alleviating the obstacles in
the way of enterpreneurship and
encourage them to achieve their own
dreams and hopes and in order to do that
we need to provide them with some basic
seed funding it the region is a float
with with the petrol dollars and one
good use of this petrol dollars would be
to redirected back to the region
specifically to help the youth
specifically to target women projects
specifically at small
the small and the medial enterprise so I
believe it's that the question should be
how can we focus the growth to make it
more inclusive of groups that have been
left out in the past it's not a question
of how can we actually accelerate that
growth per se